Hanover's idyllic old town the city
wants to make sure its visitors and
tourists don't miss a single site or
attraction that's why they came up with
this little red line
it runs 4 kilometers through the city
guiding you to 36 of its most important
sites including plenty of examples of
Hanover's royal splendor this city was a
seat of royal power for more than 200
years home to the later Kings of Hanover
from one of Europe's oldest noble
families this was supposed to be their
new palace but the king of Hanover was
stripped of power by the Prussians in
1866 and never got to move in instead
the palace remained empty for ten years
until a university took over the
building
and overs Opera House is another example
of royal architecture the king wanted to
locate the building in what was then the
city center and the architects had to
fight hard to get their project on its
outskirts approved but in the end
Hannover grew and developed around the
Opera House Hannover continued to grow
in size and splendor under Prussian rule
- with buildings like the new city hall
today it's become a landmark curious
visitors can take a tour exploring its
interior all the way up to the roof from
the dome visitors have a tremendous
panoramic view of Hanover
right in the heart of the city the
man-made Mashti lake is one of Hanover
as many green oasis
and so were the banks of the liner River
the spacious Gorge garden is a landscape
park created in the English style and
it's a favorite among students
visitors taking a stroll for the Royal
Gardens are transported back to the 17th
century The Grocer garden or great
garden was the centerpiece of the
electors summer residence it was
envisioned and realized by Electress
Sophia of Hanover who wanted to create a
sort of ballroom outdoors the central
focus of the garden is this fountain
which shoots over 80 meters into the sky
for both locals and visitors picnicking
at the royal residence is a special
treat and don't leave the Royal Gardens
without seeing the famous grotto
designed by Nicky to some five here the
artists created a magical world made of
colorful mosaics its accents like this
that revealed a modern face of Hanover
was controversial bananas sculptures are
now an integral part of the city Hanover
has been investing in open-air modern
art since the 1970s and some of it ends
up in the city's pedestrian zones even
an overs bus stops have a special Flair
some were designed by international
artists
of course there's art indoors too like
in the August Kastner Museum the
building itself is an important
attraction for art lovers the block like
structure is wrapped in walls of
concrete latticework and covered with
five thousand windows inside visitors
find a range of design objects
the Sprenger museum focuses on
contemporary and classic art
a world-renowned Museum it features up
to 25 different exhibitions every year
whether taking in the cultural
attractions or relaxing outdoors in its
parks and gardens Hanover is certain to
delight